can I say one sentence a different way
that makes people realize like nothing
good comes of not doing something you
want to do because you're worried about
what somebody's going to say
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
my name is Anthony here as part of the
team dream the NFC I got I get to spend
a week at the office here with team
garyvee and Gary himself I got to kind
of Shadow different members on team
garyvee sitting on meetings and kind of
see behind the scenes of what goes on
for the footage that we get to consume
so it's pretty fun
[Music]
it's a lot to take in yeah it's like I
think you come into it you know even
with meeting you I think my expectations
are getting met like you know you kind
of you wonder oh is it really like this
right there's always that there's always
a human protectionism of not wanting to
be let down yeah yeah I agree when I ask
myself you know when you're 80 when
you're 90 are you gonna like are you
gonna wish you did it or not right and
are you gonna whether it's your mom your
dad your brother a former relationship
your best friend or just anybody do you
think at 80 or 90 you're going to be
happy that you didn't do something
because of their opinion versus not
doing something that was in your stomach
last week first time like you know
posting a video like putting my face out
there huge it's it's something small for
so many but for me brother you want to
hear something insane the smaller group
is the ones that are putting their face
the silent majority that's not posting
their faces much bigger than people like
me notice how that combo just went hey
it seems like a small I know it's small
for so many people but I put my face on
it no no no no most people don't put
their face on it kind of like the
iceberg you know that's exactly what it
is it's back to how I talk about
happiness everyone's like the world
sucks I'm like no no the negative people
are just loud right now until positive
people get louder you won't understand
the context you won't understand the
math I can't be such an enigma
I need more people that are positive to
get loud like I do
foreign
[Music]
this is Anthony and you're listening to
the disruptive podcast today we have our
first guest and he's no other than
garyvee himself how you doing today Gary
I'm well brother I'm uh I'm pretty
excited to be on episode one the whole
mission of you friends is kind of
amplify your voice to scale garyvee and
not just garyvee like you know like I'm
passionate about certain positive back
attributes but just to amplify good
that's scary
would you still have gone ahead and
launched a few friends without the nft
without that technology like did the
timing the timing line up or because I
feel like you're at that Pinnacle where
the answer is probably right to your
point I'd already had the meetings of
launching a toy business I feel like I
have a long way to go on the garyvee of
it all and I could but
that doesn't change the fact that my
voice doesn't resonate for a lot of
people I'm empathetic to that and to
your point yes I feel like the timing
was great
um but the technology and kind of what
was happening in the space really spoke
to it
[Music]
so much
cheers
[Music]
what's up Gary how are you it's great to
see you my friend everybody Welcome to
the first episode of the marketing fees
of success where we plant seeds for
business growth I'm honored to introduce
Our Guest for this show none other than
the legendary Gary vaynerchuk Aiden it's
great to be with you my friend is Word
of Mouth alone but so
a reliable way to grow a business
especially again for a local contractor
like a landscaper
honestly I'd prefer that person to spend
you know what they can afford on social
media because I think or Google because
I think it will Social will help them
grow you know I'm not going to sit here
and say you have to run marketing
there's too many people watching right
now who've only Built their business on
Word of Mouth word of mouth is powerful
my big point about that is like why
wouldn't you want to double your
business if you could afford it and it
didn't create anything negative for you
like work life balance like why would
you know like it's kind of like that
Facebook movie right like you know
what's better than a million a billion
kind of thing like that whole thing it's
like yes you can build a three million
dollar a year landscaping business with
just word of mouth because you have a
big enough wealthy enough area where
you're the guy you're the gal for the
last decade my question is like why
wouldn't you want it to be 5.3 million
because you were good at Facebook and
Google and not or all right correct I
can see it as a amplification of word of
mouth in a lot of ways especially with
social of course is it just it goes back
to one's ambition let me thank you Gary
for for coming on here thanks for having
me brother my next meeting's here so I'm
gonna run I love you Aiden I wish you
well see you later Gary what's going on
man how are you life is good brother
thank you for asking it's been a long
time and it's good to see you here it's
great to see you if you could place one
bet on what would bring in the next 10
million nft owners what would that be
and has this always been your bet or is
it something new
a significant organization at scale
makes a real play for the technology the
NFL converts all of its tickets to nfts
versus QR codes Carnival Cruise the way
you get on is an nft now not an email
confirmation Mass integration for
normalization if you ask me this about
QR codes which is a great technology I
would have not predicted there'll be a
global pandemic that will shut down the
Earth for a couple years and during that
time restaurants will use QR codes for
menus and the timing of the iPhone
having it default into the photo app
will work and then like you know what I
mean like so it's not going to be any of
the things I just said it's gonna be
something left field but I think it's
gonna be like that like something that's
at scale people say it's scary actually
what he's like you know Gary is what
he's like and he's 10 times more you're
the man you've always been great to me I
appreciate you being on here today and I
wish you the best of luck man I'm
sharing for you brother thank you for
those kind words we'll talk soon thank
you Team all right peace peace welcome
to another episode of sports cards live
with your host Jeremy Lee
[Music]
tonight's guest needs no introduction so
let's bring him right out Gary
vaynerchuk welcome to sports cards live
how are you doing pal I'm well brother
how are you I'm good I'm good Gary it
only took me about two and a half years
to get you on the show welcome thank you
for making the time I gotta do something
somewhat ceremonial right off the bat
I gotta grab that take that off my wall
that's been up there for two and a half
years I'm very flattered my friend thank
you thank you for coming on so listen we
don't have a ton of time I'm gonna jump
right in and I want to get your thoughts
on the trajectory that the hobby has
been through since 2019 the national in
2019 where I first met you through the
pandemic to today what are your thoughts
you know I think it's an industry that
got much broader uh awareness much like
many Industries sneakers nfts cards
um anything social media like markets
um it's a market that I think is in a
really healthy solidified place because
it went through its underrated period
potentially it's overrated period in
this cycle you know we had the McGuire
era we had the 80s junk wax era you have
these moments where two three four years
but every time you look at it I find
like the industry evolves and gets
stronger sports cards have been a thing
in popular culture obviously for over a
hundred years and have had real
understood value now for almost a half a
century right the amount of people that
have come into the industry is
extraordinary and so I think the Hobby
and I've been watching The Hobby pretty
carefully now for the last year I think
it's in a very healthy place right on
well I saw your booth at the Nationals
last year it was low-key it was great
your passion exudes uh from me as a
lifelong passionate collector do me one
favor before we sign off give a shout
out to my buddy Jason we call him the
worm dog he's a big fan of yours worm
dog thank you for the love I hope I see
you a bunch of times at these shows and
throughout the upcoming years my friend
stay well
Carrie is exactly how you hope he is in
real life uh you know when you're
consuming his content you're like damn
is he really this nice like is he really
like you know kind and is helpful and he
really is and everyone on the team is as
well the best thing about today's but so
far has been like my expectations have
been met uh you know coming in here you
have really high expectations you know
that everyone's gonna be as you imagine
they are and and so far so good so it's
been awesome
foreign
[Music]